.
Vincent Bonnay.
- Le mont Sima, la plus grande
station au nord du 60e parallèle
est peut-être la seule station
au monde à compter plus
que de kilomètres de pistes.
DAVID MCNEIL, entraîneur-chef,
Équipe élite de l'Estrie
- Le mont Sima, c'est la plus
belle montagne pour le début
- Pour cette équipe d'Estrie,
s'entraîner à plus de 4300 km
de chez eux, c'est un choix
- Le réchauffement de
la planète, c'est toujours
difficile au Québec d'avoire e ;
fafafait qu'on aime autant
ne pas prendre de chance
absolument qu'on fasseun certais
de ski avant que la saison
qu'on vient ici. C'est
notre petit secret.
- Un petit secret qui commence
cette année, le mont Sima a
accueilli des équipes venues de
l'Ontario, du Québec,
Colombie-Britannique,
d'a,a,a,a, mais aussi d'Oregon,
d'Alaska et même du Japon.
Une opportunité en or
t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t te
de consécration, à la tombéede t
possession des lieux.
♪ ♪ ♪
IEIEIEIE BLOUIN, membre,
Équipe Snowboard Canada
- C'est le seul endroit oùgegege
aussi tôt, puis où est-cequ'on t
adapté pour s'entraîner.
- L'équipe nationale dméméméméms
olympiques s'entraînent
sur le big air.
- Des fois, en Europe, encore
tôt comme ça, c'est de la ne
Donc là, on a vraiment
un feeling, dedededede vraie
neige et puis c'est ça, il fait
froid ici, donc ça nous prépr,r.
- Une nouvelle saison va
commencer, les Jeux olympiques
d'hi
sait? Les Yukonnais pourront
peut-être dire q
sur leur petite montagne
que tout a commencé.
Radio-Canada, W